In the years that went by,
there was a formidable aspiration to bring immigrants to our country,
probably because they were paid less well than others,
less well than the French than the French workers.
We went looking by charter and by whole truck.
They were dumped in France,
in our large factories,
especially in the Paris region.
And then well,
these people,
they settled down,
they founded their families very often,
they sometimes married French women and they lived...
And it becomes very difficult to treat them without nuance.
And yet,
the Moro government has taken steps to
facilitate their repatriation to their home countries,
giving them certain benefits so that they can also leave.
This is where the number must be reduced,
of course,
but it must be done with respect for the law and with respect for people.